[Music]
the nice thing about a project like this
uh is especially trying to operate
in that universe of idealism that wonder
woman creates
is the ability to kind of shine the
spotlight on female creators and
non-binary creators writers and artists
so being able to work with people like
danielle page who wrote serena williams
stories tracy sorrell cami garcia who
writes so much
for dc comics but this time she talked
about greta tunberg mickey kendall these
were just people i've worked with before
people who are friends but they're also
great wonderful writers
and then i want to do a shout out to
saeeda temafonte because she was the
letterer on my wonder woman graphic
novel and she also got to do the
lettering on the marsha p johnson story
now i have to say that the other people
who deserve a shout out is all the dc
editors who worked on the project this
is a a project of love and there are
many many hands who cut help lift up all
these wonderful wonder women around the
world
[Music]
there's two that really stand out for me
one is olugbamisola ruday
story about maricopani mario is that
amazing american
she's not a child anymore but when she
was a little girl she started the fight
for clean water for the people of flint
michigan that just is mind-boggling it's
been happening for years and years in
flint michigan
maricopa comes from a family who were
really strongly connected to the
community and and believe in activism
just like wonder woman
the other story that just
gets me every single time
is a story of edith windsor that one is
called how one woman's love changed a
nation and it was written and
illustrated by a wife and wife team this
is a story of edith windsor who after
her her wife's death fought for
recognition that they were in fact a
married couple this was before some of
the um the laws were changed that
allowed gay couples to marry legally and
this again it's a story where you see
the characters growth over time but
they're what never changes about them is
their love
except maybe it even deepens
[Music]
oh golly yeah dr francesca neka okay so
she's this amazing scientist from
nigeria boundary breaking she's become a
physicist has been an activist for women
and girls in stem just not only in
nigeria but all over the african
continent
the story was written by dr sheena c
howard who herself is a game changer she
was the first black woman to win in
eisner dr francesca is a new person to
me but is just opening up a whole door
of new information for me
it's about keiko uh ajayna this story is
called asian americans bff written by
sarah kuhn illustrated by lynne yoshi
lynne is so talented and her ability
to bring emotions out of of the page and
to just kind of reach out and
it's so easy to empathize with the
characters in the starting story and to
understand where the writers was coming
from to understand the impact that keiko
ajina has had on our country lynn just
hit it out of the
park wonder woman means the world to me
i was of that generation the kind of
between you know
between
women getting the vote because both of
my grandmothers remember when women got
the vote my mother grew up in a very
traditional kind of conservative world
my mom had a job but she was really
looked down on it by some people in her
community for having that job i can
remember when i was a kid
seeing the jobs in newspapers in two
columns
and then the jobs were sorted into jobs
for men and jobs for women just the the
amount of of injustice for for women who
identify people who identify as female
when i was a kid was astounding and
the only place where i saw things being
broken
boundaries being broken rules being
really bad rules being broken
was on the wonder woman television show
she was a woman uh who got to be strong
who got to be physical who got to be
athletic
and that sense of justice right and i
think that people
who have had to fight to get their own
place in the world they understand
justice in a deeper way
than people who are born into privilege
she really helped shape me i i will
always always tip my hat to her for
helping make me who i am
[Music]
[Music]
you